hey guys correct knuckles here and today
I have a bit of a pre-emptive video now
that I've started making more YouTube
videos and being more involved with
YouTube the frequency of fake natty
accusations has picked up so the point
of this video is basically to explain
why you can be relatively confident that
I have not used anything of course since
you're not me and you don't live with me
thankfully you you can't know for sure
but you know kind of explain why you can
be pretty confident that I haven't and
also just to explain why I happened also
first things first
for people I'm linking this video -
because you're trolling me so I'm
trolling you right back
first I just want to say thanks because
your accusations let me know that I'm
making my gains and that that truly
touches me deep inside lets me know my
hard work is paying off ok so first
things first why you can be relatively
confident that I haven't used so most of
the accusations stem from one of two
sources one either my beard is too damn
good to be Matty I'm not even going to
touch that one because I really don't
have a good defense for it the second
one has to do with how much I lift I've
totaled 1885 in competition most people
who don't use drugs or who do use drugs
usually don't get particularly close to
that so with that in mind people think
oh you lift that much so you must be on
drugs
however when you put it in context that
number really isn't overly impressive so
just some background my first
powerlifting meet was in the spring of
2007 it was a local APF meet and for all
intents and purposes I was basically
untrained at that point I've had like a
some
they're long high school weight training
class but I mean the programming was
garbage it wasn't really structured it
was I mean it was basically just like an
hour-long bench and bicep session every
day so I actually was fairly well
treated from the bench press squat and
deadlift not so much we would squat any
time the coach was in a particularly bad
mood so about once every like two weeks
or so and he led a squad super high so I
didn't have much experience squatting at
least properly and deadlifts weren't in
the program
I think I'd done deadlifts with a
Olympic barbell like maybe twice at this
point so basically untrained I learned
how to squat pehoe parallel and I
learned that I needed to pause my
benchpress literally two days before the
meet so not much experience and in that
meet I totaled a thousand and seventy
via a 365 squat 285 benchpress and a 420
deadlift 420 attempt selection was not
intentional I was fifteen I didn't know
what that meant but in hindsight gives
me a little chuckle anyway so that's
that's when I was like 15 fast forward
about eight months I competed in the
first row unity meet as a very light 220
and I totaled 1438 there and that that
number was a little bit low I got red
lighted for depth on a squat that was
about 28 pounds heavier than the one I
got credited for and I got red lighted
for hitching on to deadlifts that I
locked out there were about 30 pounds
heavier than I got credited for so I got
that 1438 on the books realistically you
know if I had more experience competing
it would have been closer to a 1500
total of investment that's neither here
nor there
that was basically my noob gains
actually doing a so much structured
program going from that tense
the total to a mid 1400 total so like
that was that was basically what my
starting point was and from that point
to this point was basically moving from
mid for teens to high 18 s so
proportionally you know let's say you
start with a like five six hundred pound
total and you get to a thousand pound
total just proportionally that that's
basically what I've done I was just a
naturally strong dude and I've trained
smart so I've gotten stronger so yeah I
mean 1885 is a big number but I mean I
was I mean I just got a very lucky draw
for lifting weights so it's really when
you put it in context it's not nearly as
big of a number as it seems so yeah
that's that's the main reason why you
can be relatively sure that I don't use
so why I haven't used so a lot of times
people automatically assume that when
someone says they're drug free that
that's like kind of a moral injunction
against people who do use just because
we have so much cultural baggage around
steroid usage that really doesn't bother
me I don't care if you use or not that
I'm not going to make a moral judgment
about that the reasons I personally
haven't used one and most importantly is
steroids are illegal and I don't think I
would do particularly well in prison and
I don't really want to find out that's
that's really if I'm being totally
honest that is 99% of the reason why I
haven't used I have just never I don't
know I'm just I'm a boring person I
don't really do any illegal things I
speed
that's about it so that's that's the
main thing the other thing is I like to
drink a lot not a lot I'm not an
alcoholic I promise but I do like beer
and but alcohol is rough on your liver
and steroids are also rough on your
liver so the way I see it if I used that
would leave me with one of two options
either risk compromising my liver health
which I don't particularly want to do or
not drink beer as much as I currently do
which I really don't want to do so
that's that other 1% of why I haven't
used steroids sorry I really don't have
too much more to say about that so
thanks for watching the video and like I
said if I'm linking this to you because
you think that I was on I just want to
thank you again for noticing my sweet
gains and because this is YouTube I'm
sure a lot of people are going to
completely ignore everything I just said
and play the game of guess Greg stack in
the comments so if you want to do that
feel free that's about it all right
thanks guys bye